la parole est un monsieur sébastien
huyghe
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues l'état impartial promis par
françois hollande en 2012 a fait long
feu
bernard roman françois brottes pierre
rené lemas ce adeline hazan thierry le
paon dominique voynet vincent feltesse
dominique berly bertinotti
la liste des nominations est longue pour
illustrer le bilan de recasage de cette
république des copains il y a quelques
jours nous apprenions par voie de presse
la future nomination de notre collègue
rémi pauvros à la tête de la société du
canal seine nord europe
votre secrétaire d'état aux transports
rappelait d'ailleurs dans cet entretien
à la voix du nord que l'état étant
majoritaire il emportera la décision en
clair circulez ya rien à voir
alors que le conseil de surveillance ne
s'est pas encore réunie qu aucune
concertation n'a été engagé sept
nominations arbitraires s'apparente à du
mépris pour les collectivités locales
partenaires de l'état dans ce dossier
je rappelle que le financement de ce
projet a pu être finalisé grâce à un
effort supplémentaire de 50 millions
d'euros de la région hôte france qui
investit donc au total 352 millions
d'euros dans cet ouvrage
cela ne suffit pas semble-t-il pour être
associé à ce choix
rémi pauvros ayant perdu sa mairie de
maubeuge en 2014
est ce à dire que le gouvernement
anticipe sa défaite aux législatives en
lui proposant dès à présent un recasage
sur mesure
monsieur le premier ministre il vous est
encore possible d'apaiser les tensions
suscitées par cette nomination il est
encore temps d'engager une combine une
concertation avec les partenaires de
l'état enfin dans un climat de défiance
particulièrement aiguë pouvez-vous
garantir devant la représentation
nationale tué ainsi que la demande et
xavier bertrand président de la région
haute france la fonction de président de
la société canal seine nord sera
bénévole et qu'aucune rémunération
d'aucune sorte ne lui sera attribuée par
ailleurs confirmé vous l'engagement de
l'état que les appels d'offres seront
suffisamment bordés afin qu'il ne puisse
pas y avoir de travailleurs détachés sur
ce chantier
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre bernard
cazeneuve
monsieur le député lorsqu'il y a des
sujets qui permettent à notre pays dans
grange d'engager des grands chantiers
des grands chantiers qui sont demandées
par des formations politiques
différentes qui vont permettre
d'améliorer considérablement le
transfert modal qui vont permettre
d'avoir des infrastructures de transport
qui créeront de l'activité et de
l'emploi alors que tout cela a fait
l'objet de nombreuses discussions avec
des collectivités locales qui ont permis
de dégager des consensus sur les
conditions de financement
vous ne pouvez pas vous empêcher plutôt
que de vous en réjouir que d'abaisser le
débat politique avec des considérations
de petite politique qui inspire
désormais toutes les questions de votre
groupe
alors vous me permettrez de ne pas me
placer à ce niveau-là et de remettre les
choses en perspective avec une certaine
préoccupation de ce qu'est l'intérêt
national de ce qu'est l'intérêt de la
région dont vous êtes l'élu et de ce que
doit être la relation entre l'état et
les grandes collectivités locales
lorsqu'il s'agit de sujets de cette
nature quel est le fond de la sphère le
fond de la faire c'est qu'il y a un
projet qui lorsque nous sommes arrivés
en situe à lens en situation de
responsabilité était un concept qu'il
avait fait l'objet d'aucune initiative
de votre part qui n'étaient pas financés
et qui aujourd'hui grâce aux initiatives
de ce gouvernement et notamment grâce à
l'action que j'ai conduite sous
l'autorité du président de la république
lorsque j'étais ministre des affaires
européennes bénéficient d'un financement
à hauteur de 40% de l'union européenne
au titre du mécanisme d'interconnexion
europe et à ce que vous n'avez pas
soulever et qui est un élément
déterminant de la réussite de ce dossier
nous avons engagé des discussions avec
les responsables des collectivités
locales les régions concernées de
manière à faire aboutir ce projet est ce
que vous appelez une magouille pour nous
c'est la construction d'un projet
d'intérêt national et d'intérêt européen
dans une discussion apaisé et
constructive avec les collectivités
locales
mais vous une discussion apaisé
constructive avec les collectivités
locales
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est parce que
vous êtes dans un tel sectarisme que
pour vous toute question doit être
antagonisent à sion confrontation et
abaissement
enfin je voudrais vous
indiqué que sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres sur la gouvernance sur le
financement
j'ai des contacts avec le président
bertrand comme j'en ai eu d'ailleurs sur
le démantèlement de calais dans un
esprit de responsabilité et de respect
qu'il ressemble en rien au ton de votre
question c'est ainsi que j'entends sur
les grands dossiers conduire le
gouvernement de la france et je vous
laisse à la polémique et aux
abaissements du débat politique dont
vous êtes désormais coutumière